qu'est-ce qui cloche à Château-Renault
depuis l'arrivée en 2020 de Brigitte
Dupuis à la tête de la commune les
règlements de compte politique se
multiplient cette fois le maire est
l'air doit faire face à une vague de
départ de salariés la CGT parle
d'aménagement toxique l'opposition sans
mail quant à l'élu elle dénonce une
cabane romain Delphine
des employants dépression des
changements de poste forcés des mises au
placard à la mairie de Château-Renault
des agents municipaux salarmes des
conditions de travail et sans son plein
auprès des élus de l'opposition
plusieurs agences sont venus vers nous
par téléphone ou physiquement pour nous
parler de leur mal-être
et de leur désarroi
beaucoup trop de pression beaucoup trop
de
tension
d'interdiction mise en cause la mer
Brigitte Dupuy réagit et ni tout
management toxique et y voit une volonté
de la part de la CGT et des oppositions
de lui nuire on peut peut-être parler de
commente parce qu'en effet c'est pas du
tout ce qu'il en est réellement ce sont
que quelques personnes en fait depuis
mon arrivée il y a des personnes qui
sont parties donc ça a été aussi une
évolution de carrière il y a aussi des
personnes qui ont voulu en effet ne pas
rester avec la nouvelle mairesse même si
on ne se connaissait pas et il y a aussi
du personnel que je continue à rémunérer
et qui sont toujours pas là donc ça
aussi il faut l'entendre
pour se conseiller municipal de gauche
le climat politique est délétère à
Château-Renault et rejaillit sur le
personnel municipal sur les réseaux
sociaux comme on conseille municipal
oui qui voulait parler donc la mère
plusieurs fois répétait non non vous ne
vous ne pouvez pas parler je vous donne
pas la parole et ça a duré je pense ça
paraît lourd mais à mon avis bien 5 10
minutes vous avez eu cet échange vous ne
pouvez pas parler à ma collègue
insistait elle a le droit quand même
mais non elle voulait pas donc voilà
c'était ça des procédures
administratives et judiciaires sont en
cours même si on apparence chaque camp
souhaite que le dénigrement laisse place
à l'apaisement